hello
people and non-people however you
identify
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message for march
3rd 2021 and i'm actually
in a spectacularly wonderful
fantastic mood because i saw
real people last night and we are gonna
show you
evidence of it yes anything can happen
here in crazy los angeles before i get
to that real quick just a reminder guys
please subscribe to the youtube channel
there's that little notification bell
there
click it this week has been a
particularly bizarre situation
uh with youtube there the the
suppression seems a little higher
than usual some of our jordan peterson
videos uh definitely are not
seeing the numbers that they should be
seeing because my inbox and every other
way you guys communicate with me
they're all absolutely blown up and
people are saying this is like the best
interview i've ever done it was just so
great to have jordan back
and just having jordan return you'd
think that these things would be blowing
up there's something
a little weird going on over there on
youtube which by the way i don't know if
you heard about this that's why i
started a tech company
called locals.com and you can join us
and not be algorithmically
algorithmically manipulated at
reubenreport.locals.com all our stuff's
there
ad free and all that good stuff we're
only doing three stories for you today
uh because i want to focus uh mainly on
the first one because it was just so
great to see actual human beings
we're going to talk about the la meetup
that we did last night and just sort of
the bringing together
of political refugees and and and los
angeles refugees finding each other and
and hugging and touching it everyone
wants to touch me they always want to
touch me
they don't believe that i'm a real
person they want to touch and they
always ask to hug and
there's a whole situation uh then we're
going to talk about uh president joe
biden
gave some covet updates yesterday and we
may be doing this for another year if
not infinity and beyond we'll find out
about that
and then the big story of course of
today is that new york governor andrew
cuomo
just had a live press conference uh
within the hour i was actually on
outnumbered on fox news for the full
hour this morning and they kept warning
us in our ear
oh we may have to cut you because
cuomo's about to give
uh this press conference so he just gave
a press conference really addressing
the sexual harassment allegations there
are now three women
that say that he had sexually harassed
them over the years
uh but also in part related to obviously
his his complete botching of the covid
response
and it's just so crazy it's one of those
things
where for like eight months the media
was treating this guy like a king he
wrote a book about management of kovid
yeah you know how to manage a state in
effect during a crisis he
wrote that book yeah he wrote it that's
right he got an emmy
in the midst of all this everyone was
saying he's going to be attorney general
in the biden administration well the guy
is is crumbling and burning we're going
to show you some video from the press
conference
and then i will analyze uh but before we
get to any of that guys
uh last night we did a live meet-up
here in los angeles and it was
truly we can show you a couple pictures
about a hundred people
showed up to a random bar in los angeles
i did this
only for members of the locals community
because obviously i'm not just going to
tweet out my location because you're not
going to believe this guys not everybody
loves me
there's a couple people out there
usually
genderless anime street fighter avatars
who don't like me so i can't just tweet
out oh i'm going to be at this bar
so we did it at rubenport.locals.com
posted where i was going to be
i posted it earlier in the morning
because people came from all over
california people came from northern
northern cali like six hour drive people
came from even
more southern socal all over the place
we had about 100 people at a bar
we drank we ate we laughed
we smiled we talked and it was truly
like
i really can't even properly explain
really how wonderful it was it was
first off really like the most fun like
it was just fun like
seeing people and and all these people
coming together and you're not going to
believe this guys who's crazy
crazy because you know i'm a radical
freedom extremist and for the people
that watch this show a lot a lot of
political radicals
there were white people and black people
there were men
there were women there were gays there
were straights
there were all sorts of not only were
there all sorts of people
but there was a lesbian couple that
i'm gonna was about the lesbian couple
there was a lesbian couple that was just
doing some food shopping across the
street
and they saw this huge crowd and they
came over
and they didn't know what all these
people were doing there but we met with
the lesbians
and the lesbians had a good time so we
had everybody okay
everybody was there celebrating freedom
and uh it was it was just phenomenal but
here's if you didn't see it already i
posted it this morning on twitter
uh here's just a little video because
what happened was somebody showed up
people first off there was an incredible
girl who showed up
she baked muffins for everybody and she
had dave rubin for governor's sign and
people were giving me bottles of wine
and bottles of whiskey and
all sorts of trinkets and all sorts of
great stuff
um but one woman who was there brought
the recall gavin newsom uh
paper you know the thing that you're
supposed to sign and again you can't do
it digitally they've made this extremely
difficult which is why it's so beautiful
that there's almost two million
signatures because they made it really
hard to do that you had to do it in
person during a lockdown
when you're not supposed to go out about
two million signatures we only need the
1.5 but it's great to just get more so
anyway so this woman comes up to me
she says dave if anyone here hasn't
signed the recall yet we got to get
everybody signed it so we started asking
around and
literally everybody at the bar had
signed it we finally
found one guy who had not signed it and
here's
a little video hey gavin newsom
dave rubin i know you know me man listen
we're doing an
outdoor gathering here in los angeles
got about 100 people here we're eating
we're drinking we're talking about stuff
and we got a nice lady who brought the
gavin newsome recall
and pretty much everyone has signed it
already so but we finally found a guy
this guy over here had not signed yet so
use my back
you can use my back sign in the avenues
to recall
anyway sending my best hope everything's
good up in
sacramento and look forward to seeing
you at your retirement party at french
laundry
that's right guys i am going to host the
gavin newsom retirement party because
we've got to get rid of this guy
right now in california we are now the
last state that still has gyms closed we
are the last state
to have no indoor dining it is
completely ridiculous when i drive down
the main drag that i live off over here
it looks like a war zone things are
still boarded up
everything's closed office buildings
completely empty all the mom and sh
mom and pop store is completely closed
completely gone it's absolutely
ridiculous
this is a bad man and he deserves to be
recalled
and hopefully not only will he be
recalled but then we got to get a crop
of people
that are good enough to get in there and
and will
the crazy one-party lefties of
california
actually wake up and vote for somebody
else vote for
perhaps someone more centrist or even
dare i say it
scary right wing a guy like rick
grinnell do you think it might be
possible
a guy like the scary adam corolla i
think anything's possible
um in any event we went out the the
owner
of the bar was thrilled that we were
there this is a guy that i met
at a protest who had who owns many
different bars and restaurants all in
the socal area he's had to lay off a ton
of employees he
he was so thankful that we were there
and and it was just something else it
wasn't just about
it wasn't just having fun and and like
laughing with people and having drinks
it truly like every single person and i
tried to make sure that i had at least
you know a minute or two with with
everybody that was there and if if you
were there and i didn't get to say hi to
you i'm sorry but i think i got
everybody i really tried to
um it was more like there was this
like unspoken like oh this is the way
life used to be this is the way life
is supposed to be like think how messed
up that is that just
people meeting at a bar for drinks
and wings and burgers and assorted other
foods that that would be a special and
rare thing
in 2021 and if you wanted to wear a mask
there you could
and if you didn't want a mirror mask you
didn't have to and that's the way life's
gonna have to be
going forward if we're going to have
anything remotely close to a semblance
of freedom
so it just it felt very special i got to
tell you when i when i got home and i
did have a couple of drinks i was i was
a little drunk but when i got home like
i really
when i put my head on the pillow i was
like this
was a great day it was a great affirming
day and and i just want to say one other
thing for all of you
that that were there um you know it's
like everyone thanks me oh dave you know
you're saying all the stuff that that i
believe or you're helping wake people up
or you help woke me up or whatever
but i truly truly mean this which is
that you guys have given me
as much if not more than i've given you
because once i
when i see people again and then i it
helps me frame
all of the stuff that i talk about you
know what i mean like i think
one of the reasons i've been able to
stay sane in the last couple years is
i don't think first off i don't even
think i'm that special and i don't think
i'm better than any of you guys or
anything like
that i am one of you guys and when i was
on tour with jordan peterson i always
loved going out into the crowds after
and meeting people
jordan did too was a little more
difficult for him um
because of just the schedule and the
craziness and the level of fame wasn't
so insane and everything
else but doing meet and greets and i'm
going to do more of these we're going to
keep doing them in socal but
every place that i travel i promise you
i will keep doing this for
for members of our local community uh
and by the way we're working on setting
up a tour again we're trying to figure
it out it ain't easy right now texas
by the way just opened up fully
yesterday no masks
but guess what you're not going to
believe this and this is the cool thing
about freedom
if you want to wear a mask you can wear
a mask
pretty great but they are no longer
going to impede businesses
from moving forward they're no longer
going to stop people from living the way
they want to live but again
then you should take what precautions
you think are necessary and get
vaccinated if you want to get vaccinated
and everything else but yes we are going
to work on a little tour situation i
think we're going to start with probably
five or six shows
in about a 10-day span in florida
probably in april we're trying to put
the pieces together on that
right now but i do like that florida and
that's where we're going to start it all
right guys we got two more
stories for you but before i get to it i
want to talk to you
about smartmail you know free email
services like gmail and yahoo
aren't really free i've been talking
about this for quite some time
you pay with your privacy and since
those companies have
access to every email you send and
receive big tech can sell your data to
the highest bidder
from business plans to medical records
companies can sell your personal data to
target you with intrusive ads
and open you up to identity theft and
phishing attacks
that's why smart mail i'm sorry that's
why start mail
wants to secure your email and make you
feel safe again
start mail keeps your email private
period every email is encrypted
even if the recipient doesn't use
encryption
which means big tech can't read scan
analyze or sell your data
or information ever start mail also
prevents government agencies from spying
on you like in dragnet operations with
start
mail deleted means deleted when you
delete an email it's gone forever and
start mail uses
their own servers not amazon's which
means they can't
nuke you and put you out of business
just like they did to parlor
start mail is also backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited anonymous
aliases this feature protects your main
email address from spam and phishing
attacks
so when you're giving your email to a
company but want to protect your
identity
start mail can generate a shareable
alias email so people can't sell your
info
and they can be deleted anytime here at
the reuben report we've been looking for
alternatives to google so we're excited
to start using our own start mail
account michael's getting on it today i
don't trust big tech and neither should
you
start securing your email privacy with
start mail sign up today and you'll get
fifty percent off your first year
go to startmail.com ruben that's start
mail
with the t s-t-a-r-t mail.com
rubin for 50 off your first year start
mail.com
reuben and now back to me okay so on the
heels of talking about
people actually meeting other people
making choices for themselves
opening up businesses living life you
know things that we used to
take for granted that now seem precious
and rare as i said earlier
well president joe biden although he's
president and that's his title but i'm
pretty sure he's not in charge of the
operation
he had some some interesting info to say
about kovid and and sort of the future
before i throw into this by the way it
is now i believe the 87th
day of no can't be the 87th day of his
presidency
probably what are we about how many days
we're in where we're about uh
what two and a half no could be about 87
days does that sound about right
february no we're whatever it is about
50 days in
trying to do the math in my head here um
and he has not given a full press
conference yet
uh meaning a press conference where he
actually just stands in front
of the media and answers unscripted
unrehearsed questions
he's occasionally given a speech and
then he'll take one or two questions
this this was one of those incidences
this is from msnbc this is joe biden on
when america
might return to normal i've been
cautioned
not to give an answer to that because we
don't know for sure
but my hope is by this time next year
we're going to be back to normal
and before that my hope but again depend
upon if people continue
to continue to be
smart and understand that we still can
have significant losses
there's a lot we have to do yet so thank
you
my hope is by this time
next year we might return to normal
my hope is by this time next year
we might return to normal should i
repeat that 20 times in a row
um guys it's march it's march of 2021.
you may remember and part of why it's so
difficult to stay sane these days is
they try to memory whole everything
you may remember all the way back to
march of 2020
that was a year ago and that's the month
that they told us two weeks
to flatten the curve and now a year
later
we may return my hope is by this time
next year that's what the president of
the united states is telling us
now ironically he's telling us that just
as
texas as i just said is fully opening
mississippi
is fully opening we know florida which
has largely stayed open although they do
still have mass
mandates uh did not lock down
and the numbers are low there the places
that it's the worst are the places that
have locked down
coupled with now what we know about the
rates of suicide and depression
and alcoholism and everything else so
why should we trust these people anymore
i'm not a conspiracy theorist
i'm not a crazy person all i am is
someone who wants to go about
living my life and wants other people to
go about living their lives
as they see fit and unfortunately what
has happened here in essence is that the
system has tested us
the system over the last year whatever
you want to call that system however you
want to define that
thing has tested us and it pushed us and
it manipulated us and it basically said
to us what can we get away with can we
could we lock people in their homes for
a year and destroy their businesses and
make them more dependent on all of us
and will they push back will they do
anything and in most cases
we did absolutely nothing and the system
saw that and then even this morning
i saw an article about how the next
thing we'll need are climate lockdowns
right because there was a there
literally was a story this morning
i think maybe it was in business times
i'm not sure about how uh
co2 emissions because everything was you
know much more quiet in this past year
and we weren't in cars as much and all
that
that that went down so maybe every two
years we should have these intermittent
lockdowns
the system tested us and it saw that we
don't
fight back and that's why we need to
start fighting back
and we need to start living our lives as
we all see fit you know it's like i can
repeat myself
into into ad nauseam here um but that is
the only way this is going to move
forward is that
we are going to have to do it we the
people we can't just expect
that gavin newsom is going to suddenly
get it right you can't just expect that
andrew cuomo is going to suddenly get it
right and you can't just expect
that joe biden is going to do it right
these people in some way with power they
get
off on the fact that we've given them so
much power and they just
want more and more like do you think joe
biden
first off that he even knows what's
going on or even is in charge at this
point is just sort of ridiculous
but do you think actually he really
cares you know he pretends i'm joe biden
from scranton pennsylvania and i
really care about the average people and
i'm from delaware and it's like
no you don't because if you cared about
the average person you would let
them live their life which is what all
that's all people want
at this point and i'm gonna keep
fighting for that and uh
and i was thrilled that uh so many
people had signed that gavin newsom
recall maybe maybe we've got to get a
presidential recall going have we ever
had one of those
i don't think so but maybe maybe we need
that because if you're telling me that
maybe
kinda we can sort of get back to
something next year
what joe i thought you ran on that you
were gonna solve this thing that that
trump was a buffoon
and didn't do anything even though
operation warp speed got us the
uh vaccines faster than could have
humanly been imagined and when trump was
talking about vaccines back in uh
back in what was it probably may maybe
even earlier than that
april everyone said it will never be
done this year and then of course it did
get done this year
they're giving me some info right now
some breaking information
the u.s constitution does not allow for
the recall of a president
outside of the impeachment process i
guess that i guess that makes sense
there's
there's an impeachment process meaning
that the three branches of government
have to work their system it's it's not
that we can just leave it up to
a recall and in many ways although i was
slightly kidding when i said it that we
would actually have a recall like
the chaos that that would cause at a
presidential level would be so nuts
so although i was slightly kidding it's
like it would be better that things be
left
to the branches and the checks and
balances and all that and it's not like
i mean
you guys know this it's not like we
would have sham impeachments it's not
like we would impeach
a president for like a fake russia thing
and spend a year focused on that and
then and then can you imagine
it wouldn't be like a bunch of people
after they failed with that one
would then impeach a guy who wasn't even
president anymore it's not like
something like that would happen so that
would just be nuts
so you know i think i think we're gonna
be okay uh moving on from
from one inept leader to another uh the
the main story of the day
is that andrew cuomo who is the governor
of my home state
new york whose father mario cuomo was
was a pretty great governor democrat
centrist
um he is in a lot of hot water right now
there's two things happening so the big
the big thing in my estimation the thing
that is more legit
and needs to really be dealt with is is
the covid stuff right
we know that he sent elderly people back
into nursing homes
and that is where kovid spread and
that's where a lot of people died that's
on him
by the way this is not debated by
anybody i mean google this everyone
knows this now he also quote wrote a
book about leadership
during a pandemic in the midst of all
this he also got an emmy a lot of
celebrities really love this guy
uh he comes off as basically just like
this mafioso who's
who's accountable to nobody and i think
you're going to see a little bit of that
in this clip we're going to show you in
just a sec but that
to me the the way he has dealt with
covet and the way he has destroyed his
state
and that new york city is basically a
ghost town i get it he's not the mayor
of new york city and they have the
completely inept
borderline evil i would say bill de
blasio and new york has a reckoning
coming and
and andrew uh andrew yang is running for
mayor of new york city and hopefully
maybe that'll work to fix this thing uh
who the hell knows but but new york much
like california has been largely
destroyed
thanks to andrew cuomo okay so that to
me the covid stuff
the lockdowns that's the real issue now
there's this issue that
that three women have come forward and
said that he sexually harassed them over
the last couple years
now i'm not diminishing those
accusations and let's remember of course
that over the last few years we've been
told to believe all women right when
when brett kavanaugh was uh being
confirmed as supreme court justice we
were told believe all women
and me too and all that then when
allegations come out again against
democrats then it's like i don't really
believe
all women i mean kind of believe the
women that we sort of think are
believable when it goes for the guy that
we kind of like and
you see how this game is played but in
any event the lefties are the ones that
have said believe all women
now one of their guys one of the
progressive heroes
is is being accused of sexual harassment
so he has these two scandals
basically breaking at once uh there's
also
some people in the in the house the new
york state senate that are thinking
about impeaching him so he's got like a
whole bunch of stuff
anyway he gave a press conference this
morning and
well you listen to it for yourself and
you tell me if this is a man that sounds
contrite
and honest and is going to fix the mess
that he got himself into
uncomfortable felt hurt felt pain
from the interactions
and i'm embarrassed by it and i feel bad
by
from it i'm not in this business to make
people
feel uncomfortable i'm here to make them
to help them that's the essence of
what i do what i do
the i do not believe
i have ever done anything in my public
career
that i am ashamed of
i didn't know i was making
um her un uncomfortable at the time i
feel badly that i did
but and i'm i'm gonna learn from it
marcia asked me about you know my usual
custom is to kiss and to hug and and
make that gesture so i just want to be
very clear about something obviously i
don't like andrew cuomo politically like
right like you get it i don't think this
is a good
uh governor i don't think this i don't
think that his governing philosophy
is anything close to a governing
philosophy that would make sense
in a world that was right um i am not
saying he's guilty of anything you know
if he
if he patted a girl on the back or he
you know there's this video where he
asked i guess i think was a reporter to
swallow a whole sausage hole i mean
there's some
there's some stuff that he did is any of
that stuff beyond the pale is any of
that stuff anything other than joking
around
or that he might be feeling you know
touchy-feely
and he's italian obviously and italians
often talk with their hands and are very
verbose and all of that stuff and might
be a little more affectionate and all
those things so i'm not even i'm
actually making
no commentary on what he did or did not
do
okay and my guess is like no one's
accusing him of rape
right no one's accusing him of exposing
himself or anything of that level
but the monster that you guys created
the monster
that we must believe all women that we
must destroy
people who politically we disagree with
well you fed the monster
and then the monster looked around there
was no more food and then the monster
started looking at you
and licking its chops so whatever
happens to him related to this it's his
own doing
but i just again i want to be clear i'm
not saying that he actually did
necessarily do anything there's there's
a couple things actually my guys are
giving me the three things
uh apparently an ex-aide asks said that
cuomo asked her
about her sex life okay that's probably
not appropriate
if that's true and again it's if it's
true you know just because someone makes
an accusation this is another one of the
issues that we have right now
just because you're accused of something
doesn't mean you're guilty of something
but okay an ex-aide
says that he asked her about her sex
life that's number one number two is
another
former aide said that the governor
kissed her
on her lips okay if if he did do that
that that does seem like you can't kiss
your subordinates
on their lips okay you can't do that
sorry guys you can't i can't
do that around here okay that that's not
good you can't do that and a third woman
recounted
an unwanted advance from the governor at
a wedding i think that's the sausage one
right and i think there is video of that
where he's like telling a woman to
swallow sausage oh
okay which is a party trick i'm not
necessarily saying
that you know to make you popular in
certain circles i'm not saying i'm
truly i'm not saying it's good or bad or
anything else those are the accusations
and then i guess for society it's up to
all of us to grapple with those things
and
if his own base will turn on him his own
base that has said believe all women
the patriarchy is evil he's also white
that doesn't help
so they're going to have to decide on
that but again to me that is the
sideshow if
if the reckoning is to come for this guy
the reckoning should come related to
covid the related that they did not
follow the science
that there is no evidence that lock
downs work period although you're not
going to believe this here in california
gavin newsom's been tweeting up a storm
in the last six weeks guys the numbers
keep plummeting
six weeks plummeting plummeting is there
something
somebody remind me one of you guys what
happened about six weeks ago was there
something that happened
about six oh right joe biden became
president right that was the thing i
knew there was something that happened
six months ago
uh six weeks ago so you get the point of
all of this guys so anyway so he has to
deal with that so there's two scandals
here we'll see what happens
but what i what i will end on is this
which is
if we are to recall gavin newsom and
it's going to happen one way or another
and then hopefully we actually get rid
of them so it's not just about the
recall you got to actually vote in
somebody else
but if that happens and if the pressure
becomes too much for cuomo and he
actually steps down
well then maybe all of the lunacy that
we're seeing right now
all of the overbearing politicians who
think they can manage
all of your lives while they can't even
manage their own and don't even live up
to their own rules and regulations and
all that stuff well maybe the dominoes
will start falling and maybe that will
be the thing
that get us to the great reset not the
great reset they want the great reset
that we want
which is actually that there will be
more liberty there will be more freedom
there will be more of an ability for you
as an individual to live the life that
you see fit
that's what i'm hoping for and that's
what i'm praying for and that's what i'm
going to keep pushing for
guys if you have not watched it already
my two hour interview with jordan
peterson is
up right here on the youtube and of
course it's available
ad free at reubenreport.locals.com and
we've got a whole bunch of stuff
big stuff actually happening with locals
that we'll be able to announce in the
next couple weeks
thanks for watching have a great day and
i'll see you tomorrow